pour débuter un nouveau cycle d'audition
cycle consacré à l'avenir du fret
ferroviaire
ce sujet intéresse au plus haut point
notre commission qui avait d'ailleurs
confié à Nicole Bonnefoy rémyreau il y a
environ 2 ans le soin de conduire une
mission d'information sur le transport
de marchandises face aux impératifs
environnementaux sujets sur lequel le
frais de ferroviaire constitue une
partie de réponse pour décarboner le
secteur des transports pour initier
cette mission notre commission avait
organisé en décembre 2020 une table
ronde consacrée à l'avenir du transport
ferroviaire de marchandises réunissant
l'alliance 4F le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures SNCF réseau ainsi que
la direction générale des
infrastructures des transports et des
mobilités des jtm deux ans plus tard il
nous semblait nécessaire de faire un
point de situation sur le frais de
ferroviaire français
comme vous le savez depuis cette table
ronde plusieurs évolutions sont
intervenues dans ce secteur et nous
sommes ravis d'accueillir Monsieur
Raphaël doutrebande est président de
l'Alliance Fred ferroviaire français du
futur
qui représente tous les acteurs de la
filière en France pour les évoquer pour
réaliser un point d'étape sur la
situation du transport ferroviaire de
marchandises
avant toute chose nous souhaiterions
prendre le pouls du secteur du transport
de marchandises par le rail et de son
développement que nous appelons de nos
vœux depuis des années nous avions
d'ailleurs adopté à l'initiative du
rapporteur Philippe Tabaro un article
dans la loi climat et résilience Daoud
2021 fixant l'objectif du doublement de
la part modale du fret ferroviaire d'ici
à 2030 d'après vous cet objectif est-il
toujours atteignable dans les conditions
actuelles avez-vous
identifié les évolutions législatives ou
réglementaires pour y parvenir je
rappelle que d'après les données du
ministère de la transition écologique la
part modale du frais de ferroviaire dans
le transport intérieur de marchandises
s'établissaient en 2021 à 11% contre 9,6
en 2020 et alors même que cette part
modale était en diminution depuis 2015
nous nous réjouissons de cette dynamique
mais nous souhaiterions savoir si
d'après vous la poursuite de cette
tendance haussière est envisageable dans
le contexte actuel en particulier nous
inquiétons de ce que l'enquête conduite
par la Commission européenne sur la
régularité de plusieurs mesures de
soutien à Fret SNCF qui représente 50 %
du trafic Fred français ne conduisent
non seulement à bouleverser la situation
de Frat SNCF mais également à
déséquilibrer le secteur du fret dans
son ensemble si Fred SNCF est membre de
l'alliance 4F nous avons bien conscience
que 4 F n'a pas vocation à s'exprimer
pour l'un de ces seulement membres et
nous entendrons d'ailleurs sans doute
Fret SNCF à la rentrée mais cette
procédure de fait concerne l'ensemble du
secteur c'est pourquoi nous
souhaiterions vous entendre sur la
manière dont vous envisagez les
conséquences de cette procédure pour la
filière
par ailleurs plusieurs documents ont été
publiés et on vocation de manière plus
ou moins ambitieuse à donner des
perspectives aux frais de ferroviaires
je pense notamment à la publication de
la Stratégie nationale pour le
développement du frais de ferroviaire en
septembre 2021 composé de 72 mesures je
pense également au contrat de
performance entre l'État et SNCF réseau
s'il n'y en avril 2020 notre commission
avait conduit ainsi que d'audition au
printemps dernier sur le projet de
contrat et tirer la sonnette d'alarme
sur son manque d'ambition pour le frais
de ferroviaire français aussi
pourriez-vous monsieur le Président
nous faire un point sur la mise en
oeuvre de ces documents documents à la
fois stratégique pour les développements
du Fred ferroviaire et le contrat de
performance
enfin janvier au moyen allouer au
secteur du fret ferroviaire depuis les
mesures d'aide déployées à l'été 2020 le
secteur a bénéficié de diminution des
coûts de péage mais aussi de soutien
l'investissement matière d'installation
terminale de votre service et
installation de tri de wagon ou encore
de modernisation des lignes capillaires
frites en août lors de la remise du
dernier rapport du Conseil d'orientation
des infrastructures la première ministre
a annoncé un investissement de 100
milliards d'euros à l'horizon 2040 dans
le ferroviaire le gouvernement a
également annoncé en mai dernier un plan
de soutien de 4 milliards d'euros pour
le frais de ferroviaire d'ici à 2032
d'après vous
quels sont les moyens et les moyens
sont-ils à la hauteur de l'ambition
qu'attendez-vous de la traduction
concrète de ces annonces avez-vous
éventuellement d'autres attentes de la
filière à partager avec nous enfin et en
lien avec un sujet connexe qui intéresse
au plus haut point notre commission
qu'elle regarde portez-vous sur les
dernières annonces du gouvernement mais
aussi des collectivités concernées
relatives au financement de la liaison
Lyon Turin je ne serai pas plus loin et
je vous aide à présent la parole pour
votre propre introductif je laisserai
ensuite mes collègues vous interrogez à
leur tour je vous donne la parole ce
plaisir merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs dans
les questions que vous avez posées je
vais dans le propos liminaire répondre
déjà à un certain nombre de de vos de
vos points mais évidemment n'hésitez pas
à nous interroger l'alliance l'alliance
4F que je représente en tant que
président avec Madame Florence Rodet qui
est notre délégué général vous remercie
de nous auditionner on répond évidemment
très faiblement très favorablement à
votre invitation et on souhaitait
apporter quelques précisions en effet
après la l'homme et la loi climat qui
porte l'objectif de doublement introduit
comme vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur le
Président par le Sénat
l'État a initié des mesures qui ont eu
un premier effet positif nous plaçons
sur la trajectoire du doublement entre
2020 et 2021 la part modale du Fred
ferroviaire est passé de 9,6 à 10,7
c'est pas beaucoup mais au moins ça a
progressé
au 1er semestre 2022 nous avons
également enregistré une très forte
activité mais depuis le mois de juillet
alors que les demandes des clients sont
là la profession est confrontée à des
difficultés assez inédites qui ruine
beaucoup de nos efforts en raison du
coup de l'énergie et de l'impact
dramatique des grèves quatre mois de
grève évidemment fait beaucoup de mal
aux frais de ferroviaire
en chiffres c'est -19,6% sur le trafic
conventionnel et c'est moins
23,5% sur le combiné
pendant ce temps le frais de ferroviaire
de marchandises pour ce qui s'accrase sa
croissance chez nos voisins européens en
Italie avec plus 22% par rapport à 2019
et en Allemagne plus 10% et 2% de
croissance en Suisse
pour mémoire l'investissement
public par dans le secteur ferroviaire
et de 45 euros par habitant en France il
est très froid moins qu'au Pays-Bas 9
fois moins qu'en Suisse trois fois moins
qu'en Autriche et deux fois moins qu'en
Allemagne et en Italie donc nous sommes
un petit peu les parents pauvres de
l'investissement public dans
l'infrastructure
nous avons cessé d'alerter nous avons
pendant des mois et on a fait face à un
mur du silence vous vous l'avez vu nous
nous sommes manifester dans plusieurs
tribunes les tarifs de l'énergie ont été
multipliés par 4 entre 2021 et 2023 pour
l'ensemble des opérateurs
la filière n'a eu aucun soutien adapté à
ses spécificités je rappelle quand même
que si le frais de ferroviaire n'avait
pas fonctionné pendant la crise du covid
l'activité économique s'arrêtait je
pense que beaucoup l'ont oublié
je sais que certains d'entre vous ils
sont sensibles et surtout au Sénat mais
je kit détonnais quand même à le dire
puisqu'on oublie quand même que c'était
en 2020 et que le frais de ferroviaire a
fait tourner l'économie
donc comme je le disais la filière n'a
pas eu de soutien adapté à ces
spécificités le résultat
c'est un report modal inversé qui se
traduit par les chiffres de la RT du
deuxième semestre 2022 et ce n'est que
le début le début 2023 est encore plus
mauvais
au-delà de l'année 2022 l'enjeu
énergétique va probablement s'installer
de manière pérenne et pose la question
de sa prise en compte pour le frais de
ferroviaire
la filière appelle à la prise en compte
de ces spécificités dans le cadre de la
future loi de programmation
énergétiquement en préparation il faut
encourager le report modal car c'est bon
pour la sobriété énergétique et il faut
donc un coup de l'énergie correcte qui
mette le secteur à l'abri des coûts
fatals
le sujet des grèves de 2023 le manque
d'anticipation des grèves l'absence
d'information le service minimum par le
gestionnaire de réseau ont gravement
nuit au bon déroulement de l'activité de
la filière nous sommes régulièrement et
durablement retrouvés sans solution et
sans informations à donner à nos clients
chargeurs
à titre d'exemple j'en donnerai qu'un
seul parce que je pourrais vous en
donner plusieurs puisque vous savez que
je suis également président d'une
entreprise ferroviaire donc je pourrais
vous en parler pendant des heures mais
je pense que l'objectif est de vous
donner un exemple qui est le plus
emblématique
aujourd'hui qui est le transport combiné
rail route
ou il y a eu une perte de 35% de chiffre
d'affaires par rapport aux prévisions et
plus de 45 millions de pertes de chiffre
d'affaires
nous avons demandé à SNCF réseau la mise
en place d'un plan de mesure correctives
pour mieux anticiper et garantir un
service minimum
tous ces éléments sont co-comtants avec
l'annonce de la procédure de la
Commission à propos de l'opérateur
historique Fred SNCF
sur ce point la filière a eu l'occasion
de préciser sa position elle a toujours
défendu le principe d'une scène
concurrence sur le marché et une
coopération en vue d'atteindre
l'objectif du doublement de la part
modale en 2030
et pour nous outre la mobilisation des
acteurs du marché cela passe par un plan
d'investissement et un réseau à la
hauteur des enjeux industriels du
secteur
le plan d'investissement
et les aides sont nécessaires pour
donner une visibilité une visibilité au
secteur et surtout redonner la confiance
aux clients
dans la foulée du rapport du coi le
ministre a annoncé une prolongation une
augmentation des aides à l'exploitation
passage de 170 millions à 200 millions
notre objectif est 30 millions
supplémentaires
essentiel et sur le scellement destiné
aux wagons isolés soit destiné à
l'ensemble des opérateurs qui réalisent
du wagon isolé
prévu jusqu'en 2027 cette aide nous a
été confirmée pour être prolongé
jusqu'en 2030
le deuxième point c'est un plan
d'investissement de 4 milliards que vous
avez mentionné monsieur le président
jusqu'en 2032 de milliards de entre 2023
et 2027 et 2 milliards entre 2027 et
2032 sur la première tranche de 200
milliards l'état annoncé qu'il
s'engagerait à hauteur de 900 millions
en faveur du Fred ferroviaire dont 470
millions à travers les contrats de plan
et ta région
l'enjeu sur ce plan d'investissement
porte sur la sécurisation des
financements dont la répartition entre
l'État et les régions ou autres
co-financeurs et plus que flou
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de
visibilité sur ces financements
l'alliance 4F donc demande une loi de
programmation de ces investissements
mais par dessus tout nous avons besoin
d'un gestionnaire d'infrastructures en
ordre de marche pour délivrer l'outil
industriel dont nous avons besoin il
faut insister sur la forte disponibilité
des équipes réseau mais nous regrettons
parfois une désorganisation un
traitement différent des entreprises
ferroviaires en fonction notamment des
marchés que ce soit l'intermodal versus
le conventionnel
il faut toutefois noter une capacité
d'écoute de la direction de réseau et en
particulier de son président Matthieu
Chavanel il nous faut rapidement en
revanche des actions concrètes de la
part de SNCF réseau
quelques exemples de difficultés
concrètes que l'on peut que l'on peut
rencontrer
on se pose la question de savoir si
c'est normal que sur un axe Forbach
Bayonne donc de la frontière allemande
jusque au sud-ouest la vitesse
commerciale prévue pour un train à 120
km/h tombe en fait à 64 km heure
comment se fait-il que sur un parcours
Bettembourg Le Boulou un train qui
idéalement aurait besoin d'un même
sillon toute l'année peut se voir
proposer 40 tracés horaires différents
tous les 9 jours on change d'horaire
et c'est pas un souci d'informatique
je pourrais encore vous donner d'autres
exemples je pense que c'est de là sont
assez emblématiques l'alliance 4F a
obtenu du ministre que le mandat du
président des SNCF réseau soit nourris
d'un volet fret spécifique
4F demande la production d'une véritable
stratégie capacitaire
dédiée aux frais de ferroviaire avec de
la transparence sur la méthode des
engagements et des objectifs chiffrés
sur l'attribution des sillons traduisant
une trajectoire en amélioration sur
différents indicateurs clés et des
règles d'arbitrage
sur les travaux 4F demande que les
travaux soient mieux anticipés et
intégrés dans des plans d'exploitation
de référence les fameux per et que le
volet Fred soit traité parallèlement au
volet voyageurs pour ne pas passer à la
trappe ou être traité en seconde
en conclusion
nous avons le marché en demande de frais
de ferroviaire globalement poussé par un
besoin de verdissement de nos activités
nous avons aussi des clients qui tous
les jours nous demandent des nouveaux
tracés et des nouveaux trains
le frais de ferroviaire est plus sobre
d'un point de vue énergétique puisqu'il
émet moins de CO2 et il est moins
polluant que la route nous le savons
tous mais c'est toujours bien de le
repréciser
surtout ainsi sont sur le fait que les
infrastructures Asics existantes même si
elles doivent être mises à niveau et
pour quelques-unes développées
permettent déjà la neutralité carbone de
la filière à l'horizon 2030 sans gros
investissements supplémentaires
4F a toujours poussé la complémentarité
des modes routier et ferroviaire mais
chacun évidemment dans sa zone de
pertinence personnellement je pense que
le cours et la moyenne distance sont
plutôt réservés aux routiers et la
longue distance
au ferroviaire mais aujourd'hui certains
projets comme le méga trottes ou les
autoroutes électriques poursuivent des
objectifs de massification
clairement en concurrence avec le frais
de ferroviaire or non seulement ils ne
sont pas encore disponibles et vont
nécessiter une infrastructure lourde et
coûteuse
ces projets qui sont poussés par
certains autoroutiers et industriels
sont à notre sens irréaliste tant en
matière d'infrastructure à mettre en
œuvre qu'en raison des sommes
pharaoniques qu'il faudra mobiliser
déjà aujourd'hui le Fred ferroviaire est
3 à 4 fois moins polluants que le fret
routier et trois fois moins onéreux en
terme de coût de possession
Dieu essentiellement à l'énergie
consommée et au coût d'acquisition ou de
location des matériels
les infrastructures existantes
permettent déjà la neutralité carbone de
la filière à l'horizon 2030 sans gros
investissement supplémentaires par le
biais d'abord de la décarbonation déjà
existante avec les voix électrifiées 70%
du réseau ferré en France est
électrifiée et correctement électrifiée
et aussi par l'utilisation de
biocarburant de deuxième génération que
sont le Bessan ou connu par le sang le
HVO l'utilisation de biocarburant de 3e
génération
avec une nouvelle disponibilité en 2030
de plus le frais de ferroviaire permet
de tracter une charge 45 fois plus
lourde que le frais de routier
alors que les péages européens
envisagent une réduction de 50% des
coûts de passage au péage pour les
camions électriques
certes moins pollmant que les thermiques
mais n'oublions pas que ces camions
seront tout aussi dégradants pour les
infrastructures routières
donc pour répondre aux attentes du
marché pour délivrer une qualité de
service qui soutiennent la comparaison
avec la route il nous faut un outil
réseau à niveau
un prix de l'énergie qui convienne aux
opérateurs et au marché et un modèle
économique qui nous place dans une
situation de scène concurrence à armes
égales sur le plan des externalités
merci monsieur le Président pour ces
propos liminaires et vos réponses je
vais donner la parole à Bruno Belin
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président de votre exposé
alors on a bien compris le préliminaire
il faut doubler
le fret ferroviaire donc vraiment une
question pratico-pratique là qu'on peut
aborder dans le jeu comment est-ce que
c'est en augmentant les cadencements
donc faut trouver les créneaux pour les
organiser et puis surtout parce que j'ai
bien noté sur vos propos des nouveaux
trains mais surtout de nouveaux tracés
vous avez employé aussi d'une loi
d'investissement donc en matière
d'aménagement du territoire on est
double titre évidemment très à l'écoute
faut-il réhabiliter de nouvelles
anciennes lignes lesquelles ce servir
des gares parfois des affectés enfin
voilà est-ce que vous aviez une vision
de nos installations de nos
infrastructures qui pourraient être de
nouveau mise en service pour servir la
cause du frais de ferroviaire merci
monsieur le président
merci je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur Demilly
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur le Président bonjour même la
déléguée générale moi je souhaite vous
interroger je suis sénateur de la Somme
et je suis tout particulièrement le
dossier de barreau Roissy et Picardie
qui est une ligne ferroviaire de 6,5 km
entre Vémars et Marly-la-Ville dans le
Val-d'Oise qui doit relier la ligne à
grande vitesse de Roissy à la ligne
classique Paris Creil Amiens aujourd'hui
le projet fait face à une forte
augmentation de son coût mais aussi à
une absence de financement de l'Union
européenne qui a été annoncé le 22 juin
dernier c'est un énième bâton dans
l'Hérault de ce projet vital pour la
Picardie qui devait initialement voir le
jour fin 2025 et de ce fait les
collectivités se retrouvent démunies
face à un projet qui est passé 350
millions d'euros en 2017 à 570 millions
d'euros aujourd'hui alors ma question
concerne maintenant effectivement le
Fred ferroviaire parce que cet épisode
concerne essentiellement le trafic
voyageur je voulais savoir sur le fret
avez-vous des financements européens
pour booster entre guillemets donc le
développement de cette activité et c'est
financement sont-ils vraiment sûr
contrairement à ce qu'ils sont sur le
fret passager sur le voyage passager
merci je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur de notre collègue làlec un prêt
je vous laisserai répondre et je
donnerai une série de questions merci
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
permettez-moi
d'affirmer ici qu'il est bien que notre
commission
s'empare à nouveau du sujet il était bon
que nous fassions un bilan après les
deux cris successives que nous avons
connu
donc il est bien que la Commission le
fasse et puis il y a un événement quand
même qui est venu perturber un peu le
débat autour du frais de ferroviaire
c'est la décision de la Commission
européenne suite au recours engagé les
négociations qui produisent quand même
quelques effets et quelle culture à
l'échelle de notre pays donc voilà
en m'inscrivant évidemment dans la
démarche de la commission
mon objectif à moi et c'est un objectif
partagé j'en suis sûr c'est de
consolider quand même un certain nombre
d'arguments et d'essayer de voir ce qui
se fait de bien
de voir ce qui se fait de moins bien et
aussi de voir ce qui reste à faire
dans ce qui il y a de bien vous l'avez
dit les évolutions étaient plutôt
positives ça donne raison me semble-t-il
au mot de ferroviaire
des tendances extrêmement positives
qu'il faut souligner d'ailleurs j'ai
tendance à dire que quand la tendance
est positive il faut peut-être pas la
contrarier en tout cas le moment n'est
pas propice pour la contrarier
partant de là
je me permets quelques questions encore
une fois pour consolider nos arguments
moi je sais je suis de ceux qui
considèrent
que la responsabilité de l'État français
est engagée
depuis longtemps y compris depuis 2005
en termes de lisibilité d'affichage de
transparents des ambitions qui sont
fixées pour le développement du frais de
ferroviaire je me risque même à affirmer
que si les choses avaient été
transparentes au départ peut-être que la
Commission européenne n'aurait pas eu à
statuer comme elle l'a fait et serait
permis à la diversité des opérateurs de
se positionner à l'égard de cet exercice
de transparence auquel elles auraient
été informés donc je pense qu'il est
utile au niveau institutionnel qui est
le nôtre
que l'on puisse pointer pour partie la
responsabilité de l'État dans la
turbulence qui nous secoue aujourd'hui
mais vous avez le droit d'avoir une
autre opinion bien entendu en tout cas
votre opinion m'intéresse au plus haut
point deuxième chose
il est un élément qui n'a jamais été
qualifié en France
c'est l'utilité publique du frais de
ferroviaire dit autrement
si nous voulons éviter le report modal
inversé c'est à dire le retour à la
route
on ne peut pas exclure d'avoir à définir
demain des ambitions nouvelles de
financement de cofinancement de toute
manière
nous n'aurons pas d'ambition en matière
de développement et d'adaptation de nos
infrastructures s'il n'y a pas un
objectif politique qui est fixé non
sûrement avez-vous quelques pignons sur
le sujet en tout cas moi j'ai besoin de
fin j'aimerais pouvoir compléter mon
argumentation là-dessus et enfin donc
tout ça
vise un seul objectif
c'est vraiment d'éviter le report modal
inversé que je crains par dessus tout je
n'entre pas dans le détail ici vous avez
fort bien développé l'aspect coût de
l'énergie d'ailleurs qui pourrait
conduire les opérateurs à préférer le
train diesel au train électrique ce qui
serait quand même une aberration dans le
contexte dans lequel nous vivons mais en
tout cas j'ai pointé aussi cette
contradiction bref
pardonnez-moi d'être un peu long mais il
m'apparaît que cette mission peut être
de nature à formuler des préconisations
un peu officialisée
de nature a donné cette ambition
publique au développement du transport
ferroviaire en tout cas je serai assez
preneur de la vie de 4F sur ces
questions
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président je vous propose de répondre à
métropole
trois trois propos et trois questions
très riches
je vais je vais essayer d'y répondre et
vous n'hésitez pas à m'interrompre et à
me reprendre si j'ai oublié quelques
points concernant les infrastructures
elles existent
certaines ont besoin d'être rénovés
certaines fonctionnent parfaitement bien
certaines auraient peut-être besoin
d'être modernisés mais c'est
parfaitement identifié on a quand même
des points réguliers avec
SNCF réseau et nous savons nous les
opérateurs ferroviaires où il faudrait
faire les travaux
et c'est un petit peu ce que l'on
demande à SNCF réseau c'est de nous
consulter pas forcément de faire ce
qu'on leur demande mais de nous
consulter par rapport aux besoins du
marché puisque derrière nous il y a des
clients
permettent c'est mieux que des usagers
parce que le client il paye l'ensemble
de la prestation sans financement public
donc il y a des clients et derrière il y
a encore d'autres clients que nous
sommes individuellement monsieur le
Président parlait de tout à l'heure
avant le début de la séance de son
déplacement à Rungis les matières elles
arrivent beaucoup par camions mais aussi
peut-être insuffisamment par le train
d'ailleurs donc il y a les structures et
je crois que ce que l'on demandait ce
que j'ai indiqué dans le propos
introductif c'est une meilleure
coordination avec les acteurs
quand on nous demande chez SNCF réseau
nos trafics à l'horizon 2030 alors c'est
demain mais c'est quand même pas tout de
suite sachant qu'on a des contrats en
général à peu près de trois ans déjà ce
qu'il nous faut c'est les sillons de
l'année suivante
[Musique]
moi personnellement quand j'ai des
trains bloqués je les appelle
directement donc ce sont des gens
compétents mais il y a besoin d'une
meilleure coordination avec les acteurs
du secteur et c'est ça ce qu'on demande
et aujourd'hui le report modal inversé
que le sénateur laelec noté vous n'en
vous ne voulez pas le voir arriver mais
il est déjà là il est déjà là à cause de
la crise de l'énergie et à cause des
grèves parce que les grèves ont fait
beaucoup de mal c'est grève ou il y a
pas eu suffisamment d'anticipation ou le
passager est passé avant le fret et ou
parfois même on a dit dans certaines
régions qui valait mieux éliminer le
frais de ferroviaire des horaires de
passagers pour laisser passer que le
pour décider pardon le frein de
ferroviaire pour passer que le passager
donc on est un peu dans les paradoxes
mais qui sont pas compliqués à résoudre
à partir du moment où ça répond à une de
vos questions qui les investissements on
a besoin des investissements publics
bien sûr et on a on s'est battu pour
avoir des engagements de la part du
ministre nous les avons eu le 23 mai
enfin maintenant la question c'est
comment est-ce que ça va être financé
ça reste une interrogation pour nous
c'est là où l'État doit apporter sa part
les régions mais on peut pas uniquement
demander aux régions je pense qu'il faut
que le fret ferroviaire et l'État soient
en mesure d'attirer des investisseurs
des fonds d'infrastructures ferroviaires
à ce moment où rentrerait dans un
système peut-être de concession de de
d'obligation de rénover avec un
engagement sur la durée il faut qu'on
soit novateur moi je suis preneur avec 4
rêves de des idées qui pourraient sortir
parce que il y a derrière des fonds
d'infrastructures qui pourraient le
faire pourquoi en Espagne certains
pays européens comme l'Espagne
l'Allemagne le font
moi je me bats aussi pour ce que au nom
de l'Alliance 4F pour que notamment les
deux locomotives moins polluantes voire
hybride soit financée l'Espagne a
finances jusqu'à 2 millions d'euros par
locomotive quand on sait qu'une
locomotive aujourd'hui ça coûte à peu
près 5 6 millions
mettons-le en place ça fait maintenant
plus d'un an qu'on discute avec le
ministère de la transition écologique
pour avoir le bon document la bonne
procédure pour avoir le financement donc
est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette lourdeur
administrative dont on pâtit souvent
dans notre pays où est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce que ou est-ce qu'il y a un manque
de volonté moi je vous le dis ici on a
besoin d'un vrai investissement de
l'État il y a des promesses maintenant
qui ont été faites il faut maintenant
les mettre en oeuvre mais sinon dans
deux ans ou dans un an on se reverra et
on dira qu'on a pas avancé parce que les
investissements n'auront pas été faits
donc je pense que c'est un vrai je sais
pas si j'ai répondu à peu près à toutes
vos questions non vous n'avez pas poser
une question sur la partie financement
européen et
peut-être que
je vous avoue que aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je n'en ai pas en grande
connaissance
mais peut-être sur des projets de
nouvelles énergies comme des trains
hydrogène enfin on sait aujourd'hui que
c'est pas pour demain
juste peut-être sur la partie
financement européen en fait sur le plan
d'investissement tel qu'il a été
présenté par le ministre il est prévu
d'aller chercher des co-financements
sans qu'il est précisé de manière
extrêmement distincte là où il irait
chercher les cofinancements on a compris
évidemment qu'il y avait une part
régionale ça c'est le premier élément le
deuxième élément on peut s'interroger
sur la le financement les cofinancement
européens
simplement ce qu'on observe c'est que
dans le cadre de la première phase avec
le plan de relance
finalement les financements européens
n'ont pas été mobilisés sur la relance
du fret ferroviaire de marchandises en
revanche là où il est possible d'aller
chercher des financements européens
c'est sur la partie innovation et
évidemment la filière a besoin de
moderniser son outil de production et
pousse un certain nombre de dossiers en
termes d'innovation au niveau européen
j'ai en particulier par exemple en tête
tout ce qui concerne
le DAC pour l'accrochage automatique des
wagons donc ça c'est évidemment des
points sur lesquels on sollicite les
financements européens mais sur
l'infrastructure ça n'a pas été le cas
dans le plan de relance on peut se poser
la question sur les quatre milliards
c'est très légitime parce qu'encore une
fois ça n'a pas été précisé est-ce que
ce sera priorisé en termes de demande
par l'état français ne pas apporter de
réponse sur ces questions
merci
président merci tout d'abord je
souhaiter vous remercier pour cette
initiative d'organiser cette table ronde
sur la question du fret on était un
certain nombre de collègues dans Gérard
et bien sûr notre web Didier mendelli à
vouloir
vous accueillir et de parler de cette
situation bien sûr qui nous interpelle
qui nous préoccupe et comment ne pas
l'être quand on était ce matin avec un
certain nombre de collègues et je crois
que le président
Longeot vous l'a dit sur sur Rungis et
on voit concrètement
l'important c'est l'utilité du du fret
on a été particulièrement
interpellé par les installations qu'on a
pu voir et qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
de ce qu'on pourrait attendre pour le
plus grand marché
au monde donc
moi simplement vous avez répondu en
partie et on a déjà échangé sur sur le
constat j'aurais deux remarques à faire
d'abord un regret celui que tout
récemment le gouvernement n'est pas
voulu ouvrir le champ de du projet de
loi sur l'industrie verte pour pouvoir
recenser et motiver à l'implantation de
terminaux branchée ou même simplement de
faire de l'industrie ferroviaire une
industrie verte on avait travaillé
ensemble un certain nombre d'amendements
je regrette que qu'il n'ait pas passé
les les différentes étapes de de la vie
de la vie parlementaire surtout que avec
le gouvernement on s'est fixé ici lors
de climat est résilience cet objectif
que vous avez rappelé de doubler la part
du fret
ferroviaire dans le dans le transport de
marchandises dans notre pays j'aimerais
remercier très sincèrement les
adversaires du lion Turin ils nous ont
payé une
[Musique]
quelques pistes mais quel est quels sont
à votre avis les mesures du plan de
relance que vous souhaiteriez voir
pérenniser dans le temps et qui
pourraient vous permettre d'atteindre
l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé ensemble
gouvernement Parlement et acteurs du
frais de ferroviaire de doubler cette
part modale et d'arriver à ce chiffre de
18% et pourquoi pas même comme c'est
l'objectif à Rungis on l'a entendu ce
matin de 20%
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Guillaume Chevrollier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de Fred ferroviaire France
du futur
nous dans cette commission on soutient
le fret ferroviaire en soutien aussi
dans nos territoires la réalisation de
plateforme combinées ferroviaire pour
irriguer en lien avec nos sociétés de
transport routier et c'est
particulièrement vrai dans mon
département de la Mayenne je voulais
vous interroger sur le financement
public vous nous avez indiqué que en
France il y avait un investissement
public qui était inférieur un certain
nombre d'autres pays et c'est à dire que
le modèle économique du frais de
ferroviaire est structurellement
demandeur de d'argent public ou est-ce
qu'il peut avoir une viabilité
économique
à terme sans participation financière
d'État ou de collectivités locales
et la deuxième question c'est par
rapport à la nécessité de développer le
frais de ferroviaire mais aussi de
développer un transport de voyageurs et
le sujet c'est la conciliation dans la
gestion des sillons donc les opérateurs
de Fred Ferrière déplorent qui ne sont
pas prioritaires donc selon vous comment
améliorer cette situation pour la monter
en puissance du frais de ferroviaire
tout en permettant aussi de monter en
puissance du transport de voyageurs dans
notre pays
oui merci monsieur le Président je suis
un peu inquiète j'habite le département
de l'Aube et la ligne 4 est pas encore
électrifiée à fond et
j'ai reçu avant de venir ici à cette
réunion un mail me disant que les 14 15
16 22 et 23 juillet la ligne allait être
complètement fermée entre Paris et
Troyes c'est la pleine période de
Moisson on passe par de Nogent-sur-Seine
où il y a une vivo il faut normalement
quatre trains de fret par jour donc vous
savez qu'un train représente 53 camions
c'est impossible de remplacer par par
des camions donc voilà je vous alerte
parce que là il va y avoir un gros souci
la parole est à Jacques Fernique
oui merci ce Président
si le président on a compris donc il y a
des annonces d'investissement qui ont
été faits dans la foulée du du rapport
du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures et du choix du scénario
dit de planification écologique
qui dit planification dit qu'on peut pas
se contenter d'annonce mais qu'il faut
effectivement que tout cela se
concrétise et on a vu les incertitudes
l'absence de visibilité dont vous nous
faisiez pas
oui une loi de programmation sur ces
investissements on va voir quelque chose
qui ressemble le souhaite tous
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement
le contrat de performance SNCF réseau
qu'on avait jusqu'ici reposait pour une
large part sur l'augmentation des péages
ferroviaires donc il faut sortir de
cette logique mais on voit aussi que
pour le fret tout n'est pas qu'à faire
d'investissement et de réseau
il y a aussi une question de méthode une
question de planification territoriale
d'organisation territoriale de la
logistique
vous avez évoqué la concurrence entre le
ferroviaire voyageur et le ferroviaire
fret les difficultés de ce point de vue
là donc SK à votre sens
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait attendre des
pouvoirs publics du gouvernement et du
Parlement pour être vraiment sur des
trajectoires de doublement parce que là
on voit qu'on a progressé un petit peu
2020 à 2021 de près d'un point de par
modal aujourd'hui c'est un peu remis en
question le
l'événement assez perturbateur qui est
le démantèlement annoncé d'une pour une
part de de fret SNCF avec la question
des des trains complets des trains
dédiés dont on ne sait pas si les
concurrents pourront l'assurer par la
voie ferroviaire donc qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui serait vraiment
nécessaire qu'est-ce qu'on doit attendre
du gouvernement et du Parlement pour
arriver sur cette trajectoire là
puis juste pour mon collègue à barreaux
il est parti vous lui direz non je suis
content de voir qu'il a il a le souci de
cet axe ferroviaire Lyon-Turin essentiel
pour le Fred je suis bien d'accord avec
lui et donc l'effort de revitalisation
et de de d'optimisation de de la voix
existante je suis bien content de voir
qu'il a envie de s'y engager je sais pas
tout à fait ça qui voulait dire
bon vous êtes d'accord sur le lion purin
c'est parfait
bien merci monsieur le Président alors
je vais essayer de ne pas oublier je
crois pas d'ailleurs je crois d'ailleurs
monsieur sénateur la leg que j'ai
peut-être pas répondu à tous vos points
donc n'hésitez pas à me dire si j'ai été
incomplet sur la loi industrie verte et
sur la loi nous avons été à Bercy avec
4F puisque c'est quand même du temps que
nous prenons en plus de nos activités de
dirigeants d'entreprises ferroviaire
l'ensemble de l'ensemble des membres et
quand on a rencontré les équipes on nous
a dit qu'il faudrait passer par l'eau
par voie d'amendement puisque la partie
logistique n'avait pas été
inclus dans la loi et en effet on a été
surpris de voir que les amendements
portés par par le Sénat ont été rejetés
ce qui est quand même un peu un paradoxe
puisque on a bien noté que la logistique
verte dans la loi industrie verte
n'avait pas été pris absolument prise en
compte que ce soit les raccordements que
ce soit favorisés justement des
investissements vous avez parlé
monsieur le sénateur de est-ce que le
Fred ferroviaire a une certaine
viabilité
il y a des clients si les clients payent
le prix bien sûr que le frais de
ferroviaire est est évidemment viable
maintenant on est confronté à une
situation où le frais de ferroviaire je
le dis souvent de votre part les
marchandises ne votent pas et parfois
c'est ça rapporte moins de se battre
pour avoir du fret dans sa région que
des passagers le paradoxe que nous avons
eu pendant les grèves et que l'on a à
certains à certaines pointes c'est que
on fait passer le passager avant le fret
alors que les deux peuvent coexister je
pense que c'est une question
d'organisation des SNCF réseau derrière
je lui redis tout à l'heure Mathieu
Chabanel essaye de réformer SNCF réseau
mais il va falloir aller plus loin il va
falloir penser client il va falloir
anticiper avec les opérateurs je préside
aussi notre prise ferroviaire que j'ai
eu
le l'honneur la chance je ne sais pas
comment le dire de redresser comme quoi
on peut arriver à être rentable dans le
frais de ferroviaire donc plus on passe
de train sur les voies ce que je vais
dire est une est une chose totalement
évidente et bien plus ça devrait
rapporter chez SNCF réseau on nous dit
plus on passe de train de fret plus ça
coûte cher voilà donc c'est vraiment un
problème d'organisation et je pense
derrière de volonté politique de donner
correctement un mandat à SNCF réseau de
se réformer et de mettre
d'inscrire dans le dans le dans les dans
le fonctionnement de réseau le frais de
ferroviaire et pas uniquement le passage
donc je pense que oui s'il y a des
investissements qui sont faits au bon au
bon moment aux bons endroits et ce que
je vous dis n'est pas quelque chose de
une idée puisque nous on sait où il faut
le faire donc on sait où ça va rapporter
c'est sûr qu'il y a des il y a des
lignes où il y aura plus de passage mais
vous avez cité à côté de nos gens où je
connais bien cette puisqu'on connaît
bien ses clients là les travaux je les
dis tout à l'heure il faut que les
travaux soient faits est-ce qu'ils ont
été programmés au bon moment
c'était le sujet que j'indiquais tout à
l'heure au tout début je pense pas que
les les associations fait en
concertation à la fois avec ceux qui
auront besoin de trafic fort de céréales
à cette période de l'année puisque c'est
quand même là où il y a beaucoup de de
ce qu'on appelle de dégagement de de
train il y avait peut-être une autre
période pour le faire mais ça
je peux pas vous répondre c'est chez
réseau
après vous il y a une question sur le
plan de relance peut-être que Florence
vous pouvez le prendre c'était le
sénateur tabaron sur le plan de relance
il est clair que
le redémarrage qu'on a observé du frais
de ferroviaire et directement induit par
les mesures qui ont été prises dans le
cadre du plan de relance ces mesures en
fait étaient de trois ordres une
première mesure en fait
de 170 millions d'euros si nous parlons
chiffres d'aide à l'exploitation qui ont
été décidées à l'époque et puis les
premiers investissements en fait pour
soutenir
moderniser et commencer à développer le
réseau donc effectivement les
financements ont été mis en place et
c'est ce que c'est ce qui a permis de
produire les premiers résultats et puis
il y a une autre mesure qui avait été
décidé qui n'était pas directement liées
au plan de relance mais c'est intervenu
au même moment c'est qu'il y avait une
enveloppe de 210 millions qui avait été
identifié en fait pour permettre à SNCF
réseau d'aménager certaines plages
travaux afin de dégager des capacités
pour le frais de ferroviaire justement
et ça c'est quand même un sujet et un
point un point qu'il faut souligner
parce que ça a eu son utilité et sa son
utilité effectivement dans un cadre de
dans un cadre de travaux
[Musique]
maintenant le sujet c'est de regarder
l'horizon 2030 puisque la représentation
nationale a fixé un objectif national de
doublement de la part modale et
évidemment c'est le plan
d'investissement et de 4 milliards qui a
été présenté et qu'il nous faut aller
sécuriser évidemment ça passe par une
loi de programmation ça passe aussi par
le choix des bonnes priorités au bon
moment au bon endroit et il y a un
travail en cours en ce moment pour
effectuer ce cette priorisation
l'identité étant de de regarder projet
par projet l'impact et l'effet levier
que ça peut avoir sur le doublement de
la de la part modale donc ça ce travail
est en cours nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec SNCF réseau et des
équipes et on devrait avoir un premier
retour d'ici fin juillet pour voir sur
la base de la liste que la filière avait
proposé à SNCF réseau s'il y a une
convergence de vue où il y a des points
de discussion
merci je vais donner la parole à Daniel
Guéret
oui monsieur le Président d'abord
très heureux aussi de pouvoir vous
entendre aujourd'hui parce que
l'organisation qui est la vôtre 4F à la
mairie de coordonnées déjà les acteurs
entre vous et avec d'autres c'est un
exemple qui est intéressant
moi je pense que il y a malgré tout un
problème sur l'objectif de 2030 il faut
pas se voiler la face on peut faire des
constats et c'est heureux c'est le
président de commission de faire deux
ans après la mission Fred ce point
d'étape parce que ça permet de d'avoir
un oeil actualisé sur la situation moi
je pense qu'il y a effectivement le
problème de la synchronisation entre les
acteurs mais slcf réseau et vous je le
sais vous faites un très gros travail
sur ces questions là et les gens sont à
SNCF réseau mobilisés le problème il est
pas à mon sens vraiment là le problème
il est sur la priorisation des projets
sur la planification et sur le temps des
projets qui sont complètement
déconnectés des réalités qu'il faudrait
aujourd'hui respecter si l'on veut
obtenir les objectifs d'ici par exemple
2030 ensuite les questions qui touchent
à la clientèle à l'intérêt de la
clientèle moi je partage complètement
votre point de vue à partir du moment où
il y a des clients alors pour qu'il y
ait des clients il y a quand même une
condition qu'il faut réunir ce qu'il
faut que les clients aient confiance et
la difficulté quand même qui se pose
dans notre pays par rapport à d'autres
pays dans lesquels moi j'ai pu voir les
choses en Suisse ou en Espagne c'est
qu'on n'a pas le même degré de confiance
dans le secteur privé dans l'outil
ferroviaire en Espagne ou en Suisse
qu'on l'a pour un tas de raisons
différentes les unes des autres et il
faut surtout se garder je crois aussi de
transposer les situations de pays à pays
parce que chacun a son histoire mais
néanmoins nous avons ce problème en
France et puis le deuxième pro un autre
problème qui m'a apparaît c'est la
planification et le temps des travaux
moi j'ai eu à conduire sur 27 km de
tronçon de la ligne Rouen Orléans
céréales une réouverture au trafic
voyageurs
entre le moment où j'ai déposé un vœu et
le moment où on a inauguré les 27 km qui
sont aujourd'hui effectifs sur cette
voie réouvert aux voyageurs qu'il était
autrefois il s'est passé 27 ans
en Eure-et-Loir et dans le Loiret donc
ça m'a appris avec la SNCF à mesurer le
la notion du temps les sillons j'ai
piloté un projet de 300 millions d'euros
sur une plateforme multimodale pendant
20 ans j'aurais terminé l'année
prochaine j'ai commencé en 2004 à
Chartres 300 millions d'euros
d'investissement quand vous faites un
projet avec la SNCF sur une ligne vous
devez 4 ans et demi à 5 ans avant
réservé des sillons pour un projet que
dont vous ne savez absolument pas le
contour mais si vous les réservez pas et
vous aurez pas de signer donc je mesure
la problématique qui est la vôtre sur
des projets d'ampleur et puis je pense
qu'il y a un problème majeur c'est que
pour ma part si vous si on ne vous donne
pas la possibilité d'un recours à des
fonds d'investissement privé nous n'y
parviendrons pas
ni parviendront pas et nous serons
obligés
à une clause de revoyure parce qu'on
nous sommes en 2023 2030 c'est dans 7
ans moi je voudrais quand même un moment
donné qu'on me dise qu'est-ce qu'on
envisage qui soit réalisable dans les 7
ans qui viennent on de là les
incantations des objectifs que tout le
monde partage aujourd'hui et ça c'est
déjà une grande avancée il faut
maintenant réfléchir sur les moyens à
mettre en place pour peut-être sur un
projet emblématique qui emporterait
l'adhésion commercialement d'un certain
nombre de clients on puisse dire voilà
ce qu'on a fait sur tel secteur
multipliant l'exemple sur d'autres voilà
ce que je voulais dire en tout cas je
partage et j'adhère complètement à vous
à vos constats je pense qu'il y a une
niche commerciale importante pour les
entreprises il faudra travailler sur
l'aspect confiance ultérieurement mais
dans un premier temps les points que je
viens de soulever m'apparaissent quand
même assez essentielle si on veut sortir
des bonnes intentions et des
incantations d'ici 2030 c'est ça
l'objectif merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le président
vous l'avez dit il y a un sujet de
synchronisation je l'avais dit dans le
propos
d'introductif il y a un problème de
planification et un problème de
coordination avec réseau je ne critique
pas les acteurs et les personnes de
réseaux parce qu'ils font un travail
tous les jours qui est quand même à
relativement difficile surtout quand il
se fond danser par des entreprises
ferroviaires comme la mienne parce qu'on
n'est pas content que le le train soit
pas passé maintenant il y a quand même
beaucoup de train qui passe et quand
même aussi beaucoup de choses qui
fonctionnent je suis pas là pour
défendre SNCF réseau mais quand même des
choses qui fonctionnent maintenant c'est
un problème d'organisation c'est un
problème de volonté de réformer vous
avez parlé d'investissement
ce qui reprend un petit peu le sujet de
de
votre collègue sénateur sur la viabilité
du frais de ferroviaire c'est vrai que
si pour faire venir des investisseurs
privés
si on ne leur assure pas la fréquence la
fiabilité c'est sûr que dans une
plateforme multimodale ils vont pas
venir investir voilà donc aujourd'hui il
y a ce vrai sujet de coordination mais
ce qu'on se dit aujourd'hui est
extrêmement évident enfin on ne demande
pas des choses pour aller sur la lune on
demande des choses tout à fait à portée
de main après c'est oui est-ce qu'il y a
la volonté politique d'aller plus loin
on nous a annoncé des sommes importantes
vous avez parlé de du plan de 100
milliards annoncé par la première
ministre les 4 milliards pour le frais
de ferroviaire le sujet c'est comment ça
va être financé et je pense que c'est la
première des choses c'est comment on va
le financer nous on fait des
propositions je et on va continuer on a
eu rendez-vous avec Florence Rodez avec
les le un des conseillers du ministre
Clément brun pour lui faire des
propositions parce qu'on veut arriver à
ce que on est fortement ici on fait du
on fait du commerce tu vois donc on est
là aussi on a des encore une fois on a
des clients derrière et ce qu'il faut
c'est que ces clients soient écoutés et
que l'on puisse délivrer nos
marchandises ça c'est la chose la plus
importante après il y a des choix
parfois dans des régions qui sont de
privilégiés peut-être une ligne passager
plus que le frais de ferroviaire parce
que comme je vous le dis tout à l'heure
les marchandises es ne votent pas et je
pense qu'il faut l'avoir à l'esprit
intervention est vraiment intéressante
mais on se pose toujours des questions
aujourd'hui pour nous en tant que
parlementaire pour avoir une visibilité
à la fois des points durs et puis des
avancées parce que en fait on a peu de
documents aujourd'hui qui nous
permettent d'y voir clair on parle du
schéma national stratégique avec le plan
de relance des 4 milliards d'euros mais
vous posez vous même la question on en
est où quels sont les projets
prioritaires qu'est-ce qui est ciblé
quelle visibilité on peut avoir je
relisais une note
issue d'une table ronde du Forum
régional Fred sur la région nouvelle
Aquitaine avec les interventions d'Alain
Rousset toujours très pugnace sur le
sujet je regardais avec attention les
éléments qui étaient mis en place sur
cette région
il y a une nouvelle ligne grande vitesse
qui a été construite entre Bordeaux et
Paris on attend la suite elle était
faite aussi pour dégager des sillons
nouveaux pour développer le fret
résultat des courses pas grand chose ou
si peu on a financé une base logistique
à Cognac pour développer une plateforme
d'éclatement logistique sur clonéac et
résultat des courses elle est fermée on
y a mis de l'argent elle n'est même pas
utilisée donc quand on regarde les
choses on se dit mais enfin c'est quand
même incroyable et en termes de contrôle
aujourd'hui parlementaire c'est très
compliqué
dans les contrats de plan état région
alors c'est ce qui est dit c'est la
parole aussi d'un larousset mais il dit
d'abord les 4 milliards on les attend
quand on les décline au niveau régional
c'est Chipettes ça compte vraiment très
peu et la déclinaison dans le contrat de
plan est à la région on n'arrive pas à
l'avoir d'une manière significative donc
tant qu'on n'aura pas non plus une
vision claire en termes de planification
de projets prioritaires des
interconnexions des intermodalités les
plus structurantes en termes
effectivement de programmation on a
l'impression de parler toujours dans une
attente permanente et de pas avoir les
choses se réaliser voilà qu'en
pensez-vous
j'en pense que c'est pour ça qu'on
réclame d'avoir une stratégie
capacitaire de fraté sense2 SNCF réseau
c'est ça qu'on réclame quand vous parlez
de la plateforme de Cognac mais vous
pouvez aussi parler de la plateforme de
Niort c'est pareil ça a été construit
mais que je disais tout à l'heure si
c'est pour aller chercher des
investissements publics
malheureusement ça finit comme ça si on
est rigoureux et qu'on demande à des
investisseurs privés et qu'on s'engage
nous les acteurs économiques dans la
chaîne logistique a amené des trafics à
avoir des clients derrière des
plateformes comme cognac ou Niort
n'aurait jamais n'aurait pas soit
n'aurait pas été construite soit en
réuni le trafic donc c'est ça qu'on
réclame nous quand on parle des travaux
avec SNCF réseau c'est qu'on planifie en
fonction des besoins de nos clients je
ne connais pas les circonstances pour
les dans lesquelles pour la plateforme
de Cognac a été construite et non
utilisée mais est-ce que ça a été
anticipé au niveau business si vous me
permettez de l'expression quel était le
retour sur investissement
je pense que si on se pose pas cette
question là c'est sûr qu'il y aura pas
d'investissement privé et public et le
président Rousset en effet est assez
pushi punchy sur ces sujets là je pense
qu'on peut pas uniquement demander aux
régions de se substituer à l'État dans
les investissements soyons attractifs on
a des clients on a de l'industrie qui
veut se développer moi j'ai un exemple
d'une entreprise importante qui ça fait
maintenant plus d'un an qu'on demande à
ce que on puisse avoir un deuxième train
au départ d'une usine qui est sur un axe
je n'aurais pas l'endroit parce que
sinon on va vite le trouver surtout le
sénateur de la Mayenne mais mais on
s'est battu pour que avoir un deuxième
train voilà il fallait attendre d'avoir
un agent de circulation dans le poste et
on s'est battu je suis remonté jusqu'à
Mathieu Chabanel pour l'avoir donc et on
l'a eu alors mais donc faut être
persévérant dans le ferroviaire mais je
dis c'est demander faut demander aux
acteurs de quoi ils ont besoin
savoir combien ça coûte et surtout
combien ça va rapporter à partir de ce
moment là c'est l'équation normale d'une
entreprise et normalement c'est des
plateformes pourront continuer tout
comme des ouvertures de ligne
si je vais donner la parole à Madame
barrière
non mais après madame varaiya et après
toi
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur un sujet qui
me paraît quand même particulièrement
important qui a pas été trop évoqué
jusqu'à présent c'est que
dans le viseur de la Commission
européenne aujourd'hui
nous avons les opérations financières
qui sont réalisées qui ont été réalisés
au sein du groupe SNCF de 2007 à 2019
donc moi je pense que c'est l'Europe qui
est en train de dérailler dans ce sujet
là
l'entité fraté SNCF elle a été créée en
2009 suite à l'ouverture à la
concurrence voulue par la Commission
européenne et qui d'ailleurs cette
concurrence cette ouverture à la
concurrence avait débuté en 2006 qu'en
fait SNCF avait été obligé par la
commission d'abandonner une partie de
ces trafics et surtout le wagon isolé
pour laisser la concurrence libre et non
faussée s'installer
ça c'est une réalité cette ouverture à
la concurrence elle devait faire
merveille mais c'est exactement
l'inverse qui s'est produit donc depuis
2009 de restructuration en
restructuration les effectifs de
cheminots de fret sont passés de 14200 à
5300 fin 2022 quand même le trafic s'est
effondré bien sûr ça fait le la part
belle à la route
alors je suis d'accord que dopé par le
combiné la part modale du frais de
ferroviaire dans son ensemble était est
passé de 1 à 11% 2022 après être resté
pendant des années à 9% c'est une
réalité pour la première fois depuis
2009 300 embauches étaient prévus en
alors pourquoi pourquoi cette attaque de
la Commission européenne contre
l'entreprise publique c'est la question
que l'on peut se poser
le frais de ferroviaire nous le on est
tous d'accord là-dessus est une solution
évidente pour décarboner le transport
qui est des secteurs les plus émetteurs
en CO2
nous savons qu'il a atteint en 2021 son
meilleur niveau en part modale depuis
2017 vous le disiez très justement
10,7% et son meilleur niveau de trafic
depuis 2015 puisque c'est presque 36
milliards de temps en kilomètres le
ministre des Transports dans le même
temps annonce une enveloppe
supplémentaire pour le fret et ça a été
dit aussi de façon 60-70 millions
d'euros à 200 millions par an à partir
de 2025 jusqu'en 2030 au moins alors à
l'évidence moi je trouve que nous sommes
et je l'ai relevé mais je suis d'accord
avec nous sommes un absurde
franchement la Commission européenne
veut casser une entreprise centrale pour
la transition écologique alors qu'elle
fait de la lutte contre le changement
climatique sa priorité absolue
alors moi je j'ai envie de dire tant pis
c'est au nom de la concurrence livrée
dans fossé et tant pis aussi si cette
décision va plomber le transfert des
marchandises de la route vers le rail
voilà alors aujourd'hui on estime à plus
d'un million de camions supplémentaires
qui seraient sur nos routes excusez moi
mais je trouve que c'est un scandale
écologique voilà aujourd'hui près de 40%
du transport routier de marchandises est
un transport de transit les immenses
entrepôts s'installent sans obligation
d'embranchement ferroviaire
mieux ce qui existait disparaissent et
moi je le vis très directement dans mon
département il y a urgence à mon avis à
reprendre en main le transport ferrovert
à travers un vrai service public
ferroviaire et sortir le fret du marché
de la concurrence alors vous regroupez
monsieur le Président à la fois des
organismes publics et des organismes
privés au sein de 4F
pensez-vous pouvoir maîtriser les
velléités ou les volontés de certaines
de vos adhérents clients et garantir une
forme d'opposition ou de résistance aux
orientations libérales imposées par
l'Union européenne et dans ce contexte
qu'elle en veut quel avenir bien
évidemment entre voyez-vous pour le Fred
ferroviaire je suis un petit peu dur
avec moi
vous dites manque de coordination et là
je suis pas d'accord parce que in vivo
dès qu'on a su que il y allait avoir des
travaux sur cette ligne c'en est
inquiéter et à demander à avoir des
réunions avec SNCF réseau ils ont eu des
réunions et rien n'en est sorti c'est là
où je je pense qu'une planification de
travaux certes elle serait elle était
nécessaire mais il y a une
incompréhension de réel quand même
oui et bien pour finir je donnerai la
parole à Frédéric marchand mais vous
pouvez répondre à Madame Variat et
Madame perron en fait quand je dis qu'à
un manque de coordination c'est que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure les
travaux sont prévus deux ans à l'avance
les entreprises ferroviaires sont
évidemment en général informés
quand vous avez ce qu'on appelle avoir
des sillons dans le dur on peut pas les
changer comme ça pour l'avoir vécu on a
des il y a déjà eu des modifications de
planning de travaux donc je me doute que
le groupe il vivo que je connais par
ailleurs a demandé des réunions mais
pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas été suivi
des fichiers réseau j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est inadmissible
inadmissible maintenant je reste quand
même pour moi Madame assiatrie c'est un
problème de coordination avec les
entreprises de frais de ferroviaire
puisque c'est à cette période là où on
fait tous les dégagements donc on peut
pas fermer une ligne à ce moment-là mais
on va vous dire il faut faire les
travaux oui il faut faire les travaux
mais planifier le avec planifier-le avec
nous en plein hiver à une période où il
y a pas de trafic ou peu on peut les
planifier voilà sauf que
je vais vous dire une autre chose vous
avez au niveau de réseau Vous avez deux
organisations la partition et la partie
travaux voilà et parfois dans la
pression que ces deux directions ont du
mal à se coordonner et encore plus avec
les régions alors je sais que c'est une
grosse entreprise 55000 salariés ça se
dirige pas comme une entreprise de 850
salariés comme celle que je dirige mais
il n'empêche que il y a quand même une
coordination avec une une délégation qui
doit être en région donc oui c'est on
est dans une certaine désorganisation
quand même
et vous avez été pas entendu
oui mais c'est totalement normal ça que
je dis mettons les parce que nous
entreprises ferroviaire on discute avec
réseau c'est que on discute pas pour
nous entre nous on discute parce qu'on a
des clients qui ont des demandes donc
c'est des choses relativement évidentes
tout ce que je vous dis pareil
complètement
fou parce que normalement c'est du bon
sens alors mais où est la volonté voilà
mais on tombe dans un système peut-être
parfois un peu trop jacobin et qui fait
que de toute façon on changera pas le
système voilà
alors le sujet que vous me posez sur je
vous posez ce que vous nous posez sur
Fred SNCF est un sujet délicat pour une
raison toute simple c'est que 4F a dans
ces membres Fred SNCF du moins le groupe
R et le
que moi même je suis président d'une
entreprise privée et que le notre règle
c'est pas de donner un avis sur la
situation de l'un ou l'autre la seule
chose que je peux vous dire c'est que la
Commission fait son enquête
que il y a quand même des solutions
aujourd'hui qui sont travaillées entre
Fred et SNCF les clients pour trouver
des solutions et pour pas qu'ils
puissent continuité voilà donc il y a
des solutions de sous-traitance qui sont
envisagées avec Fred SNCF donc je crois
que c'est un sujet très difficile pour
les gens de Frat SNCF mais il y a des
solutions donc après que ça tombe au
mauvais moment c'est sûr que la
Commission a pris du temps pour en
arriver à ses conclusions là vous avez
parlé de l'ouverture à la concurrence je
veux pas que ça choque les uns ou les
autres enfin depuis que il y a eu
l'ouverture à la concurrence le marché
du fret en France s'est stabilisé il
était en décroissant avant donc
l'arrivée de la concurrence a permis
d'avoir des nouveaux acteurs des
nouveaux emplois et de stabiliser voire
même de développer donc je il a réussi à
aussi aider Fred SNCF à se réformer et
avoir une vision peut-être différente de
celle du passé je suis un souvenir de de
que j'ai retrouvé sur une archive de
Lina du sénateur laelec parlant de des
transports Lahaye en Bretagne à une
vingtaine d'années qui essayait de se
développer et qui avait des difficultés
à cause du réseau voilà donc c'était un
problème de qualité du réseau qualité de
service donc je pense que
cette situation n'est pas nouvelle la
situation de la commission Fred SNCF la
connaissait et vous parliez de du rôle
de l'État je pense que l'État est avant
tout responsable de cette situation
voilà c'est facile à dire mais je pense
que la vérité est là
merci j'ai donné la parole à Frédéric
marchand merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
quelques sites stratégies en matière de
frais de ferroviaire et quand on parle
de frais de ferroviaire dans le
département du Nord département dans
lequel je suis issu bien évidemment
pense tout de suite à Somain qui avait
3000 wons qui étaient déchargé chaque
semaine et dans l'histoire du Fred
ferroviaire un site qui a compté et la
question que je voudrais vous poser
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que vous vous
considérez toujours ce site comme
stratégique et est-ce qu'il est
considéré comme stratégique eu égard à
ce qui nous attend avec à la fois sur le
littoral dunkerquois cette explosion en
matière d'implantation industrielle plus
ce barreau fluvial que va être le canal
sendor et donc la nécessité sans doute
d'opérer de façon multimodale et donc la
nécessité d'intervenir il y a une
manifestation il y a pas longtemps qui a
été organisé sur le site avec une
inquiétude très très forte est-ce que
pour vous Somain est-il toujours un site
stratégique
chemin est quand même un endroit
stratégique entre dans le nord de la
France vers la Belgique il y a beaucoup
de trafic industriels avec et en
provenance de la Belgique donc oui le
site de Somain reste stratégique dans le
frais de ferroviaire après ça fait
partie de ces sites qui auront besoin
d'être rénovés
avec des planifications pour permettre à
des entreprises ferroviaires de d'avoir
des sortes de hub et pouvoir avoir des
transferts de wagons mais en plus avec
les développements que qui doivent être
fait à Dunkerque le canal senor j'ai un
peu plus de doute mais vous aussi
certainement mais si on parle de choses
au moins plus concrètes à Dunkerque
Somain toute cette région du Nord oui ça
fait partie des sites dans les sur les
dans lesquels Fret SNCF doit investir
mais là aussi vous le dites en région et
vous avez raison de le soulever
aujourd'hui mais tout ça ça devrait
faire partie de on n'a pas besoin de
faire des grandes commissions avec Fret
SNCF encore une fois je le répète nous
avons des clients avec des besoins
Somain fait partie des endroits où on
doit pouvoir continuer à passer et faire
des échanges de RAM et aller vers la
Belgique et plus aussi vers le sud
puisqu'on peut rejoindre l'artère
nord-est ça fait partie de ces sujets
qui n'ont pas besoin d'être réalisés
planifié uniquement en chambre chez SNCF
réseau mais avec les politiques locaux
et puis les entreprises ferroviaires
puisque c'est planifié deux ans avant à
deux ans avant ça laisse du temps
oui on sait que là aussi la ligne vers
la Chine elle fonctionne parce que c'est
l'État la Région chinoise qui finance
mais mais là par contre je doute fort de
la rentabilité de ce trafic et je pense
que d'ailleurs malheureusement un jour
ça s'arrêtera si la région de d'origine
ne paye pas mais
pour moi c'est pas des trafics viables
aujourd'hui et trafic provenance de
Chine on est plus dans une image de
développement d'un frais de décarbonée
on change une dizaine de fois
d'écartement je crois donc bon c'est pas
très c'est pas très très optimum mais
mise à part ça sans forcément arriver de
Chine pour aller à Somain il y a déjà
beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce coin
dans ce coin de France bien sûr mais
vous l'avez soulevé aussi tout à l'heure
je sais plus qui mais d'entre vous mais
vous m'en excuserez mais les les dans la
loi énergie verte les les raccordements
des plateformes oui c'est vous madame
merci Patrice ou les les plateformes ne
n'y a pas d'obligation qu'elle soit
raccordées au réseau nous l'avons dit au
ministère nous-mêmes c'est là où on nous
a dit vous passerez par voie
d'amendement donc on a apporté nos
propositions d'abonnement ici ça a été
rejeté bon donc il y a quand même un
paradoxe soit cette loi d'énergie verte
elle est pour la façade je ne crois pas
soit elle met les moyens jusque dans la
logistique
et les camions je le redis les camions
ne payent pas l'infrastructure nous
payons l'infrastructure nous payons
clairement les sillons les camions ne
payent pas l'infrastructure donc les
camions ne doivent pas être l'ennemis du
frais de ferroviaire un complément mais
chacun doit payer sa part voilà
bien monsieur le monsieur le président
général merci merci pour la qualité de
vos réponses on a bien tous en tête que
le fret ferroviaire est pour nous très
très important
mais il faut une vraie volonté et puis
de vouloir faire aboutir ce frais de
ferroviaire et je crois que chacune et
chacun devra se mobiliser pour que nous
puissions respecter les échéances et
effectivement participer à la politique
de gestion des gaz à effet de serre
merci pour votre participation et merci
pour vos réponses